hypothesis Thursday at CES the show is
almost over and Justin and I have taken
a look at a lot of stuff mostly VR
oculus is really impressive earlier
today you may have seen the video that
went up if not you should check it out
because that's really good but we also
saw some really crappy virtual reality
if you can call it that a lot of people
are definitely jumping on the VR
bandwagon nothing stands out more than
when you brand your booth with oculus
killer when you say so many different
features that your system has and then
you fail to deliver in every possible
respect there's 3d hat it is a big
Virtual Console well I mean it's not
actual virtual reality and it's
something you put on your head but it's
basically a tablet it's just in front of
your face and it's a 3d tablet so it
kind of shows some kind of 3d so it's a
virtual reality it uses outdated
technology I hear it weighs a lot it
costs $600 and if you want the
convoluted controller that has buttons
for every video setting you're gonna pay
a thousand dollars for this thing yeah
that one's a bit of a joke but of course
to do a bit of a gym yeah so that one's
a complete joke yeah but there are some
other guys who are trying some
interesting things and it'll be really
cool to see where they go one of them
eludes us all was the tool on VR yeah so
it's a mix of like augmented reality and
virtual reality and while what you're
seeing is all 3d modeled and you know
that's the virtual reality part of it
what it does is it scans the environment
and it contextualizes what it shows you
in virtual reality based on what it sees
around you essentially you had a car
engine that if you move your hands apart
it would blow up to pieces but you were
in a room and you could see the borders
and they match the room that you were in
so that's actually pretty interesting
because a thing like the oculus that
takes something that's created
beforehand outside of the context of
where you are and you kind of walk
around in that world zulan's thing
actually lets you do things that are
unique based on your environment and as
cool as oculus is we still don't have an
input solution for that yet whereas
Seulong uses your hands you hold your
hands out in front of you we can it can
see your fingers they're using something
that's
into the leap motion which is widely
available you can buy the best buy today
oculus can do that I mean there are
applications on the web that allow you
to mix the two together
oculus this isn't doing that themselves
maybe they've got something in the works
it's going to be a competitor Elle it's
something that's really scary with any
kind of VR that you wear on your head
and you walk around is that you can't
see the world around you and we kind of
stepped over one another and each other
and I'm really scared for that kind of
future but there was one other VR tech
that was also using your hands that
seemed kind of off the shelf for a
private area technology the OS VR which
was all from razor yeah razor had
essentially a VR headset that's kind of
akin to the oculus it sort of takes the
same approach to VR and uses a similar
thing like the lead motion like they
were using with the shoe on and you were
you know playing like a wizard and you
could fire fireballs at enemies that
were coming at you in ways that was very
interesting what's more interesting is
that Razer is not doing this to compete
with oculus they're doing it to
proliferate the development of new
virtual technology virtual reality
technology by opening up the plans for
the software and the hardware it's
anyone who wants to access it and then
iterate upon it
so then what you've basically got is a a
world where people people are inventing
on their own without having to get
through all the initial research and
development so they're kind of doing a
great thing for VR and down the road
Razer is going to take the best of that
maybe sell something on their own but
really their end is to create the user
interface and the controls that will
work with VR in the future so 2015 is
going to be a really big year for
virtual reality and just getting these
systems out there getting something that
you can purchase you can try out maybe
it's not the best experience yet but but
I think it's really paving the way for
what we're gonna see in 2016 when these
experiences come to fruition when we see
input devices that make you feel like
you're actually a part of that virtual
environment yeah we're only two years
into virtual reality development as it
comes to mainstream related to oculus so
we're gonna be really excited to see how
fast things ramp up now we've gone so
far so and I'm really excited for CES
2016 when all this comes to fruition to
see what that new technology is gonna be
you